[Music]
welcome to the 37th annual independent
spirit awards where we honor the best of
films and tv shows that begin with the
a24 logo thank you to film independent
everybody thank you a24 the spirit award
for best screenplay goes to
maggie jillian all for the last daughter
my film is in an unusual language it's
the language of the minds of women
i've been sort of afraid to say that
because my film is not just for women
it's for everyone too so better
every single person who was involved in
the underground railroad
there was no person who was too small in
making the project what it was thrilled
to be here today the film independent
spirit awards and this glorious tent
by the way if you're in a tent you're
camping
so get over yourselves you're fucking
camping for best international film
goes to drive my car
thank you for choosing this film about
this long long road of healing we're
truly grateful to be
have been included by building pen and
skin awards i hope that art will always
be the north star in our souls thank you
so you know this is the very first time
i've ever been here
and i've made so many independent movies
now i see that you just have to make a
really really good one
i will try harder next time
and the spirit award for best new
scripted series goes to reservation dogs
that's why we made this show because we
told stories about home and they were
all funny and there was nothing on tv
that was funny that had natives in it
and we wanted to show you how funny we
are best female lead
best male lead is simon rex for red
rocky man
taylor paley
what the fuck
thank you film independent for
recognizing my fake penis
wow like i am in shock i wrote something
because i'm not eloquent and i'm drunk
thank you brilliant janiksa bravo your
genius mine
your soul
[Applause]
thank you for having me be your solo and
the in the spirit for best feature
goes to
the lost daughter
[Applause]
we really want to thank all
of the parents especially the mothers
that came to us after seeing this movie
and felt that they were seen
that their experiences are on screen
that it's okay to not always be perfect
with everything thank you all so much
but especially to our mothers who are
brave and talented and loving and
nurturing and we wouldn't be here
without them so thank you to our mothers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you